demi leaves rehab again
when is this gonna end
sounds like a voice in my head
i can't believe i'm not dead demi lovato
is getting real about addiction and
rehab in their new track skin of my
teeth
[Music]
i think it's important for me to talk
about my experience so that more people
don't feel alone in their experiences
check out demi going full grunge in the
visual as they confront their substance
abuse battle
[Music]
at one point demi also skewers a man who
seemingly represents the tabloid press
[Music]
but the most powerful part of the video
the lyrics
you'll remember in july 2018 demi
experienced a near-fatal opioid overdose
it's something they discussed at length
in their youtube docu-series demi lovato
dancing with the devil i actually don't
think people realize how bad it actually
was
i had three
strokes
i
had a heart attack
i suffered brain damage from the strokes
i
can't drive anymore and focusing on
their sobriety is something they've been
working on since and why demi says this
new musical journey is the most
fulfilling yet it's really important to
me to
embrace my my sound as as an artist and
also become more authentic to who i am
demi's latest track comes days after
they announced their upcoming new album
holy
sharing in a statement never have i been
more sure of myself and my music and
this record speaks that for itself i've
definitely been through
a ton that's no secret to the world you
think yeah oh my goodness and i actually
you know
after going through even more stuff last
year
i came out of treatment again and during
their appearance on the tonight show
demi explained more in detail to jimmy
fallon i
realized like
i really want to do this for myself and
i want to make the best album possible
something that
you know really represents who i am and
i think the most
the the best way to do that
is and the most the easiest way to do
something the most authentic is to do it
clean and sober so yeah i made this
album you know clean and sober i can't
say that about my last album but this
one i'm really really proud about and
until we get more music from demi we'll
have this banger on repeat
[Music]